[Música]
ah
nada todavía nada me voy a presentar
primero de todo mi nombre es karim es mi
nombre verdadero es un nombre muy bonito
lo que pasa que no podemos entrar en
avión y éste es el mejor chiste que vais
a oír en los próximos 18 minutos y
porque empiezo con un chiste porque
quiero hablaros de humor y porque para
mí el humor es la mejor manera de
conectarse con las personas bueno por
esa razón y porque también soy cómico
profesional soy mago y coach qué quiere
decir esto que hago tres cosas a la vez
por lo tanto ninguna bien vale eso es
como ser español y ganar eurovisión es
imposible y había uno me gustaría irme
al origen el origen es cuando yo tenía
ocho años que empecé en el maravilloso
mundo de la magia con en magia borrás
conocéis la caja todo el mundo ha visto
la caja nadie sabe quién es borradas
pero todo el mundo desde la caja pero no
fue hasta los 28 a los que yo tuve mi
primera actuación como cómico y que en
este momento en la gente me decía pre tú
que eres mago o cómico porque la gente
necesita poner etiquetas de todo y yo
dije pero porque tengo que ser una cosa
o la otra así que decidí hacer mi primer
juego de magia
y transforme la o por la y ahora todo lo
que hago en mi vida lo hago con humor es
decir hago magia y humor
soy coach y aplico la comedia y hay una
cosa que todavía no puedo hacer con
humor que es la declaración de las
rentas pero lo estoy trabajando lo estoy
trabajando y como voy a hablaros de
humor lo que quiero hablaros es dos
definiciones que son las dos
definiciones de los cómicos favoritos de
animal el primera definición es la de
woody allen que lo vamos a ver aquí
mundial en dice que el humor es verdad y
dolor más factor tiempo amigos la
realidad suele ser muy dura vamos a
imaginar vamos a ponernos en un caso
cuando teníamos 14 15 años la mayoría de
los que estamos aquí nos hemos enamorado
con 14 y 10 años y un alto porcentaje
entre los cuales me incluyo nos han dado
calabazas con esa edad bien si nosotros
pudiéramos mirarnos con un agujero
cuando teníamos 14 años y nos estaban
dando calabazas ahora seguramente nos
hará gracia en ese momento no nos hacía
ninguna gracia
y más aún si nos dieron calabazas en los
80 porque tendríamos una pinta horrorosa
o sea los 80 han sido durísimos para
todos qué es lo que nos quiere lo que
nos permite el humor nos permite que el
drama sea muchísimo más llevadero y un
experto en hacer humor de la tragedia
fue este señor que es miguel gila miguel
gila es un cómico en la mayoría lo
conocéis es un cómico del siglo pasado
que he dicho así parece muchísimo pero
es hace 20 años y hillá como muchos
otros españoles le tocó y le tocó ir a
la guerra bueno pues lo iban a fusilar y
él pues como era un tipo inteligente
pues cuando lo iban a fusilar se tiró al
suelo se hizo el muerto y se libró de
que lo mataran bueno eso también influyó
que los ejecutores estaban borrachos
y a partir de ese momento hillá en sus
monólogos empezó a hacer humor de la
guerra esto permitió que toda una
generación de españoles pudieran
sobrellevar mejor un trauma tan doloroso
como una guerra civil si no conocéis a
gila vamos a ver un pequeño fragmento si
emilio vamos a ver qué le llamo por un
asunto de reclamaciones que de los seis
cañones que mandaron ayer vienen dos sin
agujeros
pues estamos disparando con la bala por
fuera
o sea al mismo tiempo con una piedra
gatillo otro corre con la vara
claro pero se cansa y la suelta
por donde como no vuelven
otra cosa el submarino que mandaron el
martes de color bien pero no flota
nada los llamamos razón del mandamás
recibirlo todavía no ha subido
no me digan que era un barco
conoció un trabajo hundirlo
bueno todo un maestro todo un maestro
miguel gila una cosa si no conocéis a
gila os invito a que busquéis sus vídeos
en internet vais a descubrir lo que es
un cómico maravilloso y vais a descubrir
también lo que es un teléfono fijo vale
y ahora vamos con la segunda definición
del segundo cómico favorito de mi madre
que soy yo
no podría ser leo harlem el favorito de
animales tenía que ser yo y para mí el
humor es una actitud
mirar para explicaros esto voy a contar
una anécdota que me pasó yo os he dicho
que mi primera actuación como cómico fue
con 28 años pero fue a consecuencia de
una tragedia contra mí me contratan
mucho las empresas para trabajar en sus
convenciones sus cenas de la vida y me
contrataron como mago en gijón por la
noche tendría el mediodía quedé a comer
con los amigos en madrid termine la
comida cogí el coche me fui a gijón y
cuando parqué el coche abrió el maletero
para [ __ ] mi material y no había nada
tester el maletero dije un momento que
soy mago igual aparece
no se olvide a abrir el maletero y
efectivamente me habían robado todo el
material durante la comida en madrid me
habían robado todo el material de magia
yo llamé al dueño de la agencia y le
dije mira lo que me ha pasado me han
robado el material no puedo actuar y me
dijo no no tienes que actuar porque ya
nos han pagado cosa rarísima en españa'
que te paguen por adelantado
entonces yo dije bueno pues no tengo
otra tengo que actuar y yo creo que lo
que me permitió en ese momento actuar
fue mi actitud
el humor técnicamente en la
interpretación de un hecho hay gente por
ejemplo que leche en el trabajo lo
pueden ver como una tragedia enorme y
hay otra gente que puede ser una
oportunidad para encontrar un trabajo
mejor el humor no es otra cosa que cómo
nos tomamos como cómo nos tomamos la
vida y esto lo explica muy bien más
falda más falta que es una cómica
extraordinaria en una de sus viñetas le
dice a felipe felipe no sabemos cómo
habla más falta supongamos que hablas y
felipe si quieres estar triste tienes
que caminar así
porque si caminas así no te sale
y efectivamente nuestro cuerpo está
completamente conectado con nuestra
actitud nosotros es muy difícil que
cambiemos que salgamos de un estado de
ánimo negativo solamente desde un
proceso mental también lo tenemos que
hacer con nuestro cuerpo y hacer cosas
que faciliten eso como por ejemplo hacer
ejercicio bailar jugar cantar reír
movernos el cuerpo de hecho os voy a
proponer que os pongáis a cantar que
sería horrible pero si os voy a proponer
un ejercicio para que hagáis a partir
del lunes quiero que a partir del lunes
la persona que es que le apetezca que
cuando se levante que será pues esta
vida que tenéis 8 de la mañana 8 y media
por desgracia a las seis pero cada uno
que se levante quiero que la primera
persona que os encontréis por la calle
le vais a regalar una enorme sonrisa el
95 por ciento de las personas que le son
riise os van a devolver la sonrisa
porque la sonrisa es contagiosa al igual
que el bostezo y el vómito es contagioso
luego va a haber un 5 de personas que no
se rían pero no importa porque ese 5% de
personas que no se rían se van a quedar
más inquietas diciendo de qué [ __ ] se
está riendo a las 7 de la mañana y se
van a quedar peor vale de todas maneras
quiero dar un mensaje a todas las
personas todos los tristes que no se
ríen a las 8 de la mañana
esto es él
ya sabemos que es el humor ahora quiero
explicar para qué sirve el humor bueno
para qué sirve el humor en mi caso está
muy claro si yo hago humor y la gente no
se ríe no cobro hoy no voy a cobrar
igual pero
el humor básicamente sirve para que la
gente se ría y para qué es importante la
risa bueno una de las una de las
personas que más ha estudiado esto es
este señor este señor es patch adams su
nombre es hunter doherty y han hecho una
película el doctor patch adams que es
maravillosa y cómo resumir el
pensamiento de patch adams la risa lo
cura todo la risa es beneficiosa para la
salud y también se ha demostrado que es
beneficioso para la productividad de las
empresas y aquí viene la gran pregunta
si la risa es tan beneficiosa para todos
porque cada vez nos reímos menos
en mi opinión hay dos motivos el primer
motivo es cultural nosotros desde niños
nuestros padres nuestros educadores nos
están diciendo que tenemos que ser
personas serias y formales para ser
gente de bien tenemos que ser serios y
formales como si la gente divertida no
pudiera ser brillante o si hacer bromas
no no no no pudiera ser una persona
totalmente productiva y el segundo
motivo es porque esta charla es una pena
pero a los niños no les vale porque los
niños están jugando todo el ritmo todo
el día divirtiéndose tiene la capacidad
de juego aquí aquí y su miedo al
ridículo está aquí abajo que pasa los
niños cuando van creciendo van jugando
cada vez menos y su miedo al ridículo va
subiendo cada vez van creciendo juegan
menos su miedo al ridículo sube sube
sube sube hasta que nos convertimos en
adultos jugamos muy poquito y tenemos un
miedo al ridículo aquí entonces cómo
podemos vencer el miedo al ridículo pues
siendo personas auténticas
a woody allen- una entrevista le dicen
buddy cuál es el secreto del éxito dice
no tengo ni idea pero para mí el secreto
del fracaso es tratar de gustarle a todo
el mundo hagamos lo que hagamos no
podemos gustarle a todo el mundo
esta charla yo sé que no le va a gustar
a todo el mundo evidentemente pero si no
le vamos a gustar a todo el mundo por lo
menos vamos a permitirnos el lujo de ser
nosotros mismos si os fijáis estas tres
personas son tres personas brillantes en
su trabajo y son ya personas adultas y
no tienen miedo a ser auténticos a
mostrarse como son y fijaos en sus ropas
les da lo mismo es bastante ridícula la
ropa pero les da igual ellos se muestran
tal y como son así que yo os invito a
que seáis vosotros mismos que no tengáis
miedo a ser auténticos
bueno a mí me gustaría para despedirme
porque yo he llegado aquí he dicho que
soy mago y cuando yo soy mago todo el
mundo me dice hoy es un truco lo típico
tú qué haces soy médico operarme de
menisco que son estas profesiones que
tienes que demostrar enseguida lo que
haces
y en vez de irme quiero hacer un ojo de
magia muy especial
nuevas ayudas desde ahí no te importa
cómo te llamas sergio fantástico mirá
sergio para mí es el mejor juego de la
historia de la magia es el más sencillo
pero es el mejor sergio yo te paso
cartas cuando quieras me dices alto vale
por ahí poco más un poco menos vale
sergio qué carta quieres que te adivine
está o está
y te pido que le enseñes a todo el
público y la muestra es también a la
cámara yo no quiero verla vale sergio
lo tienes
sergio estás ahí
como he hecho desaparecer gente atrás
sergio mira me queda por donde quieras
fantástico y ahora permite la rápido
mezcla rápida sergio solo te voy a hacer
una pregunta tu carta es azul
por el dorso digo
está nervioso está nerviosa si soy yo el
que la tengo que encontrar sergio
tranquilo bueno voy voy no lo voy a
hacer con la mano que la mano es de
todos los días
serge mira cómo llamarías a esta acción
lucirse esto reducirse básicamente bueno
voy a tratar de encontrar tu carta no
con la mano sino con este día es una
cuerda no está la serpiente juana
serpiente atrapa dora de cartas más
rápida del mundo vamos allá mira sergio
no tengo busca busca busca juana busca
buscar una carta una carta sergio siento
que no puede ser
el 10 de trébol
no no no es el día de trébol está
ah
[Música]
pues eso es lo que estoy preguntando eso
es lo que estoy preguntando
es que parece que queréis que me salga
mal el juego que somos de tolosa ahora
que te lo sabemos
esperate la escena un momento espera ver
mira no cómo te llamas tú y sabes qué
cartas pensado tú no te unas pensar
ninguna por eso es tan blanco espera
espera espera estaba ya agobiada
vale sí aunque tu carta es el 5 de
corazones
no me voy a concentrar
el 99 teneis prisa
mira tengo otras buenas 33 34
el 56 88
sergio el comodín que vale por todas no
vencer al verano cal ya que no salió
bien no hay tiempo tengo no estar la
estrella del tarot
yo creo yo creo yo no voy a acercar la
caja en ningún momento en un par de
ratos pero poco es mira tengo aquí no lo
vais a creer no lo vais a creer tengo un
limón
muy fuerte un limón un limón y es
increíble pero dentro de este limón
tiene que haber
dentro de un lima
una carta sergio calla calla calla tu
carta es exactamente tiene que ser
el rey de oros el rey de oros es
española
estamos muy nerviosos todos estamos muy
nerviosos
no mira mira pasa algo claro yo para
encontrar cartas necesito feedback y una
cosa no no sé si me dais una última
oportunidad ya la última y de verdad me
voy dejó nuestros ponentes por favor yo
lo que pido es un poquito de profesora
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a
[Aplausos]
bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a mí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
antes de irme
antes de irme quiero decirte una cosa
cuando yo os hablo de ser auténtico
quería que vierais que yo lo practico en
mi vida real es una cosa que digo con
esto no quiere decir que vayáis el lunes
desnudos a trabajar
porque seguramente os echen pero si os
pido que os deis el lujo de ser vosotros
mismos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah